(jazz music)
- [Kenny] This is a review
of the best styluses,
for the most popular tablets.
- The plural of stylus is actually styli.
- What do you know? You're
not even wearing pants.
- You dressed me, you foo--
(gentle music)
- [Kenny] If you're looking to cartoon,
take notes or design,
you've got lots of options.
Every year, tech companies
pitch their stylus,
and tablet combos with varying degrees,
of rhetorical flourish.
- [Woman] Our fastest S Pen yet.
- Game changing accessory.
- So I really love this pen.
- Which basically all
amount to them just saying,
buy our stick.
So I set out to find the
best tablet stylus combo,
for mixed use with an emphasis on drawing.
Tested tablets included the big three.
A 12.9" inch Apple iPad Pro.
The Microsoft Surface Pro 8.
And a Samsung Galaxy Tab S8+.
I tested styluses for all three devices.
Sadly, you can't mix and match.
So no Apple Pencil on a Galaxy tab,
or Samsung S Pen with a Microsoft Surface.
But I did throw in some
leading third party options,
for the iPad,
since it currently holds the
tablet market share throne.
All styluses were evaluated,
on a few core pieces of criteria.
Built-in comfort, pressure
sensitivity and ink flow,
and software options.
First, let's take a look
at the styluses themselves.
Look. As a kid, I collected pens.
- Nerd.
- [Kenny] As such,
I'm snobby about the feel
and weightiness of a stylus.
When it comes to the
best in-hand experience,
it's a horse race between
the $129 Apple Pencil 2,
and the $119 Microsoft Surface Slim Pen 2.
Both feel great, are easy
to use for long sessions,
have magnetic docking mechanisms,
and sturdy tactile replaceable nibs.
Which you can replace for around $20.
Where the Surface Slim Pen inches ahead,
is with its more pointed
nib and haptic feedback.
The Slim Pen vibrates lightly,
to emulate the feel of real paper.
It takes a second to get
used to but it's pleasant.
For a similar experience on the iPad,
with the Apple Pencil 2,
I had to purchase a $40
screen protector by Paperlike,
which adds friction and resistance,
but like all screen protectors,
is a pain to put on.
Samsung's $60 S Pen.
Though innovative with its soft nibs,
feels too insubstantial.
Like something you get to
keep score at putt-putt.
Also the nibs wear down quickly,
and Samsung does not offer replacements.
For a larger S Pen experience,
you can upgrade to the $100 S Pen Pro.
As for the third party options,
I like the feel of the $70 Zagg.
It's basically a clone size
wise of the Apple Pencil 2.
And the Logitech Crayon feels solid,
but looks like a relative
to the pencil Steve used,
in "Blue's Clues".
(gentle music)
Meanwhile, the Adonit
Note+ could be better.
It feels like something
you could buy with tickets,
at a mall arcade.
And one quick note when stylus shopping,
choose one with a flat edge,
or one that resembles
a carpenter's pencil.
Fully circular styluses will
roll off your couch or desk,
into some other abyss.
For me, the winner for design is a tie,
between the Apple Pencil 2
and the Surface Slim Pen 2.
The best budget and note
taking option goes to the Zagg.
Next, let's talk about
pressure sensitivity,
and palm rejection.
When it comes to illustrating,
pressure sensitivity is paramount.
Especially for pressure
sensitive brush types,
and smooth line transitions.
Only some of the styluses tested,
supported pressure sensitivity.
Those with the feature are the
Apple Pencil Gen 1 and Gen 2,
the Microsoft Surface Slim
Pen 2, the Samsung S Pen,
and the Adonit Note+.
I'm including the Apple Pencil Gen 1 here,
because the $329 entry level iPad,
only supports the Apple Pencil 1.
For drawing, I preferred
the fine pointed tips,
on the Apple Pencil 2 and
Microsoft Surface Slim Pen 2,
which offer more of a
pen to paper experience.
While the S Pen is the most responsive,
of any of the options in its own app,
it didn't perform
consistently across all apps.
Plus the S Pen nib feels a bit
more like a Sharpie marker.
And while the Adonit Note+
does have pressure sensitivity,
it's spotty at best and
nonfunctional at worst.
This is what happens
when you try to connect,
the Adonit to Procreate.
Non-stylus. No.
An Adonit spokeswoman told me,
this is due to Procreate currently
not supporting the Note+.
And then there are the styluses,
without pressure sensitivity.
These are the options more suited,
for handwriting and note taking.
On that front, the Zagg led the way,
with the Logitech Crayon 2 close behind.
The top choices too all
fared incredibly well,
when it came to palm rejection.
Maybe one little error mark there.
Overall, the Apple
Pencil 2 just edged out,
the Microsoft Surface Slim Pen 2.
Apple's option is slightly more sensitive,
to delicate line strokes.
And if you're not looking to draw as much,
the budget pick, again, goes to the Zagg.
Lastly, a stylus is only as good,
as the operating system
and apps it works with.
Between Windows, Android
and iOS app stores,
there are dozens of sketching,
illustrating, design,
and note taking apps.
After trying some of the top ones,
I couldn't shake my love for Procreate.
Which is available only
for iPad OS for $10.
The level of control and customization,
with the Apple Pencil on
Procreate is not only nuanced,
but easy to use, which
for someone like me,
who doesn't draw full
time, is very important.
And you can cheat by making
straight lines and shapes,
which I do pretty often.
- So you can't even draw a circle.
- [Kenny] And you can also
export your Procreate projects,
into Photoshop format
and keep all your layers.
Sadly, Procreate isn't available
for Windows or Android,
nor are there any current plans,
for it to be developed for them,
according to a Procreate spokeswoman.
I did, however, like
Sketchable for Windows,
which offers a similar
degree of accessibility,
Photoshop exporting, and
layered functionality.
For pros, Adobe's 9.99
per month Photoshop,
is available on both the
iPad and Surface Pro.
For note takers, all the
tablets include free apps.
Apple has Notes. Samsung has Notes.
And Microsoft has OneNote.
By far the beefiest most powerful option.
I prefer GoodNotes, an iPad only option,
just because of how easy
it is to search notes.
So what should you get?
I would get the Apple Pencil
2 and any of the new iPads.
But the competition is creeping
up on Apple, and quick.
I love the Microsoft Surface experience,
with the Slim Pen 2 and its
very fine and pointy tip.
And the super responsive
low latency Sharpie style,
on the S Pen was awfully
fun to write with.
- Is that supposed to be a mustache?
- It definitely is.